peut-être la fin du feuilleton
judiciaire dans la sphère lady di deux
ans après la mort de la princesse diana
de son ami dodi al fayed et de leur
chauffeur
le parquet de paris a requis un non lieu
général pour les photographes mise en
examen le ministère public estime donc
qu'il n'existe pas de charges
suffisantes contre les paparazzi
reportage d'emmanuel gagné dorothée
cochard et loïc le moigne deux ans
d'investigations d' expertise d'audition
rarement un accident aura donné lieu à
un tel déploiement de moyens
six enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
on travaillait à plein temps sur ce
dossier
celui d'une course poursuite entre une
princesse et des paparazzi qui a tourné
au drame
après l'accident mortel neuf
photographes et un motard de presse ont
été mises en examen pour homicide
involontaire et non-assistance à
personne en danger
aujourd'hui le parquet de paris demandé
un non lieu général pour les avocats des
photographes
c'est l'aboutissement logique de
l'enquète le chauffeur monsieur henri
paul était sous l'emprise sous l'empiré
d'un état alcoolique était n'était pas
titulaire de la licence pour pouvoir
conduire le véhicule qu'il conduisait et
pire encore conduisait beaucoup trop
vite et a priori effectivement
l'instruction a démontré que ce sont les
causes directes de l'accident qui a
causé la mort de lady diana et 2
de dodi al fayed et on ne peut pas
imputer la responsabilité de cet
accident photographe aujourd'hui le
parquet n'émet qu'un avis et aux juges
chargés de l'enquêté qu'appartient la
décision de prononcer un non lieu ou de
renvoyer les photographes en
correctionnelle sa décision devrait être
connue avant la fin du mois en attendant
la recommandation du parquet réjoui
l'avocat du garde du corps de lady di
seul rescapé de l'accident pour celui
qui défend très fort y jones les
enquêteurs se sont trompés de cible
les responsables sont pour moi ceux qui
ont obligé le conducteur à prendre cette
voiture alors même qu'ils n'avaient pas
la licence appropriée et pas l'habitude
de conduire cette voiture et qu'il était
ivre et sous l'emprise médicaments et
ceux là sont comme ça il reconnu à re
les dirigeants du ritz et l'étoile
limousine c'est à dire la société qui a
loué la mercedes
quant à mohamed al fayed le père de dodi
et propriétaire du ritz
il se refuse pour l'instant à tout
commentaire partie civile dans le
dossier
il reste persuadé que les didier et son
fils ont été les victimes d'un complot